اللهم لك الحمد والشكر الحمد لله على فرصه
الحمد لله على اللحظه التاريخيه اللي
نعيشها ما هو بس انا اعيشها احنا وانتم
سويه استمتعنا صراحه بالاطلاق ولم تاكد
انكم انتم استمتعتوا بالمشاهده
شكرا لكل من دعمنا شكرا كل ما نوقف معنا
وساعدنا شكرا لمن وصلنا لهذه المرحله شكرا
لسمو سيدي خادم الحرمين الشريفين الملك
سلمان بن عبد العزيز شكرا لولي عهده
الامير محمد بن سلمان على هذا الدعم
والتمكين والثقه فينا كشباب طموحين برغبه
بلهفه ان نحقق المستحيل باذن الله مع
دعمكم وتوفيقكم اهلي انا في الفضاء الحلم
تحقق اللهم لك الحمد والشكر وقريبا ان شاء
الله في المستقبل القديم الكثير سوف ينضم
لنا ان شاء الله ونراكم قريبا من محطه
الفضاء الدوليه لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات